america's schools spend lots of money
but often
barely educate kids our public schools
are failing
philadelphia's failing public school
district i
went to the neighborhood school elaine
wells is a mom in philadelphia
there were fights after school every day
it was
horrible so she walked her son to
another school we went to go enroll
and we were told no you can't go here
that was
my wake-up call she discovered that
although with most services we get to
shop around
that's not true for so-called public
schools
instead parents are often stuck with the
school the government assigns them
but a new kind of school's been changing
that charter schools
it's funded with taxpayer money but
hardy gets to run it
largely like a private school in
philadelphia david hardy created a
charter he calls
boys latin it tries new ideas people in
government-run schools don't like to
change they also don't like competition
from charters
but charters are often better and
parents line up
hoping to get their kids admitted a
lottery will decide which students will
stay or go
this lottery was in new york
congratulations
the winners are ecstatic but there are
many more
losers you're on pins and needles and
you're hoping and you're praying
the charter school lottery left
thousands of philadelphia students
disappointed last night it's like
you have a chance elaine's kids lost
many lotteries
it's heartbreaking but finally they were
admitted to david hardy's school
shirts are tucked in yeah that's
important to you yeah
and the kids they don't mind it of
course they mind teenage boys
the rules are there to to kind of set
the stage for the students
if the teacher can tell you to tuck in
their shirt they can tell you to be
quiet in class they can tell you to do
your homework
it gives us some authority over the kids
elaine was so eager for her sons to
attend she arranged to have ibrahim
repeat the sixth grade
i bet you didn't like that no not at all
that's when i really that was the moment
where i most despised boys letting in
every possible way but their attitudes
quickly changed before boys latin i
would come home and say okay i need you
to read for an hour read a book
and their response would be why what did
we do like
reading was a punishment right so
getting into boys latin
i would find books in the bathroom on
the floor came to the point where
the teacher would tell our mom that i've
taken too many books and then there were
the strange nighttime phone calls
he's in his room and i hear him talking
on the phone and it was like
10 o'clock at night and i'm like
you know who are you on the phone with
and he was like well mr bombolski
told me to call him if i needed help
with homework he thought he was
bothering the teacher yes
yes another change was the kids spending
more time in school
they're here from 8am to often 5 p.m
and they have to take latin it's
ridiculous nobody speaks
latin well we picked brenton because it
was hard
what's the point of that because life is
hard
because in order to be prepared you have
to work hard
and we wanted to get that into the
psyche of our students
do you feel sorry for your friends who
are still stuck in the old it's kind of
sad because i'm looking at them like why
like what you mean you're you're taking
algebra one and senior year
you're supposed to be taking pre-cut we
delivered since the very first class
we've sent more
black boys to college than any high
school
in pennsylvania and yet now philadelphia
and many other cities
are rejecting new charter applications
philadelphia rejected david hardy's plan
to open a girls latin
you're succeeding and they're trying to
kill you off because they realize that
if we continue to take children away
they won't have jobs most studies on
charters find
increases in test scores kids don't
learn as well
in most government-run schools there's
always a reason
in a government-run school for not
serving kids
they'll tell you what's wrong with the
kid they never say
it's my fault instead students are going
to march for more
funding the government schools say they
need more money
members of the philadelphia teachers
union to push for more funding
more funds get this philly schools
already spend almost
nineteen thousand dollars per child do
the math that's
almost half a million dollars per
classroom
where does the money go they have a
director special ed
and they have a assistant director a
special ed
they have a director of high school
athletics and they have an assistant
and they have all these a lot of
overhead to preserve their jobs
government teachers now say this
the publicly funded privately managed
charter schools drain
scarce resources from other public
schools drain
public fund you you can't tell me that
charter schools are taking funding from
public schools
every parent pays taxes and it's the
taxes that we pay that fund
the school system so if my child if i
choose for my child to go to a charter
school
then that's where my taxes should go
that makes sense
but philadelphia and other cities don't
even give charters
the same amount of money they give to
schools they control
they give them less in philadelphia only
70 percent
of that so the government schools make
money whenever a kid leaves for a
charter over 13 years of schooling
philadelphia saves 70 000 per child
what if they gave you the difference yes
absolutely give the rest of the money
but it would also mean that there would
be a whole lot less union jobs
and the union's not going to be for that
there are bad charters
but bad charters close bad public
schools don't close
that's a big difference when charters
don't deliver for kids
they go out of business the government
monopoly
never goes out of business